sie kommen bei einer weiteren folge von
viel okas ich freue mich ganz besonders
heute als gesprächspartnerin frau prof
hierzu haben von der universität hamburg
hockey ist herausgeberin der gesammelten
werke des kassierers wenn es eine
werkausgabe gibt dann deutet es darauf
hin dass kassierer tatsächlich ein
philosophischer klassiker ist er ist
jetzt nicht so bekannt aber viele kennen
ihn könnten sie einfach für das breite
publikum mal kurz erklären worin das
klassische von kassierer besteht in
philosophischer hinsicht muss zunächst
mal sagen dass wenn man anfängt eine
aufgabe von einem denker zu machen es
noch nicht feststeht dass er ein
klassiker sondern man hat dann so eine
grundlegende intuition dass aus ihm ein
klassiker werden leute und wir machen
allgemein jahr im umgang mit autoren die
erfahrung also autoren herausgeber
verlage dass der klassiker status durch
eine gesamtausgabe befestigt wird das
heißt man muss von anfang an den
eindruck haben dass lohnt sich und wenn
man dann diese aufgabe veranstaltet dann
wird man die erfahrung machen dass
sukzessive mit dem fertig werden der
bücher die man da herausgibt die
forschungsaktivität steigt das konnten
wir bei der ernst cassirer gesamtausgabe
in hamburg von jahr zu jahr verfolgen
weil natürlich die verfügbarkeit der
bücher dazu führt dass der autor besser
zugänglich und wenn sie nicht fragen
woran hat es gelegen dass wir und ich
den eindruck hatten dass lohnt sich bei
diesem autor dann kann ich dazu sagen
kassierer ist einer der letzten
universalgelehrten des zwanzigsten
jahrhundert er hat wohl physik und
biologie wie auch
literaturwissenschaften und philosophie
und jura studiert und das merkt man sein
denken wer an dass er
eine breite bildung und ein breites
spektrum an gesichtspunkten verfügt wie
er über menschliche wirklichkeit
nachdenkt wenn man sich fragt was ist
das eigentliche werk was ist die
leistung die man mit seinem namen
verbindet dann ist es eine philosophie
der kultur der menschlichen kultur durch
die zugleich ein fundamentaler beitrag
zur philosophischen anthropologie
geleistet sein soll
es gibt ja in der deutschen philosophie
so etwas das man heute eine
alleinstellung noch mal nennen kann also
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert gibt es eine
ganze handvoll oder einem fast ein
dutzend denker die philosophische
anthropologie betreiben die also die
frage stellen was ist der mensch was
macht den menschen aus und die dies
nicht als eine irgendwie beigeordnete
disziplin unter anderem disziplinen
begreifen sondern als die grundlegende
disziplin und zu denen gehört kassierer
und man kann bei all diesen
philosophischen anthropologen sehen dass
sie dann bei der bei der bemühung das
wesen des menschen zu begreifen und zu
verstehen um die tatsache nicht
herumkommen dass der mensch immer in
kultur erlebt bei kassierer ist es so
dass er dies von vornherein so anlegt
die philosophische anthropologie als
theorie der kultur wird das von
vornherein überhaupt nicht das
missverständnis aufkommen kann dass da
das wesen des menschen in irgendeiner
statischen überzeitlichen mit ewigkeit
anspruch ausgestatteten weise gesprochen
wird sondern der mensch wird immer von
anfang an in den beziehungen untersucht
in denen er steht und das sind die
produktiven beziehungen in denen er sich
seine eigene wirklichkeit in form der
kultur schafft und kassierer hat das
in seinem werk also die große
philosophie der kultur hilft in den 20er
jahren erschienen unter dem titel
philosophie der symbolischen formen und
steht in seinem werk in einer konzisen
zusammenfassung der versucht oder den
menschen bringt kassierer gießt dann
nochmal auf knappe darstellungsformen
und sagt dann auch der mensch ist an ihm
an symbolik um also man muss da in der
übersetzung etwas vorsichtig sein man
muss sagen der mensch ist das symbol
erzeugende und symbol verstehen gewesen
dann ist die intention getroffen
das ist eine sehr interessante
charakterisierung die mich auf die
nächste frage bringt die letzte frage
was ist eine symbolische form wie könnte
man das ganz kurz bestimmen will man das
sagen sollte nach kassieren
also man neigt dazu zu denken dass
irgendein konkretes gestaltetes harte
fakten gemeint sein könnte also wenn ich
jetzt eine halskette an der ein
davidstern hund oder ein kreuz oder ein
herzchen dann würde man dass man sagen
intuitiv das ist eine symbolische form
das ist bei kassierer nicht gemeint bei
kassierer ist ein größerer
generalisierung grad mit dem begriff
verbunden eine symbolische form ist für
ihn eine regelmäßig vorkommende fähre
der kultur
man würde es vielleicht auch sein eines
der subsysteme der kultur also die
großen aktivitäts bereiche in denen sich
menschen über alle nationen hinweg auch
in verschiedenen kulturen ihre kultur
schaffen
die sprache ist eine symbolische form
die religion ist eine symbolische
die kunst ist ein symbolisches die
wissenschaft ist eine symbolische v
dieser ausflug angelegt ja vielen dank
frau rickli für dieses aufschlussreiche
interview ich hoffe dass die zuschauer
damit etwas mehr kassierer liefern und
auch philosophisch behandeln die
grundlage ist hat dafür gegeben durch
diese werkausgabe und wir freuen uns auf
ein wiedersehen